this is the story of a very sick girl  and a set of events seen two different  ways  [Music]  very special child  she was thriving about 10 years of age  things changed she was in so much pain  the hospital was alleging the Pelletier  family was over medicalizing their  daughter over medicalizing is getting  more medications more procedures than  they need  doctors are saying Justine's parents  aren't making safe decisions for her it  just made no sense the juvenile court  decided to terminate the parents custody  Linda and I never abused any of our  children  was Justina being abused I don't  understand it  something happens that changes  everything  it's very ominous  from anonymous  that's when all hell broke loose  [Music]